hey guys while I was at PAX I got the
crazy awesome chance to check out the
Omni by virtue X which is like a
treadmill that you use to control your
character by actually running it's
insane so please check out me flailing
around like an idiot as I try to play
through half life to enjoy got it
alright I'm in it to win it ready to go
sound good alright someone take my
glasses for me thank you that's fine
it's beautiful anyway alright holy crap
oh my goodness look is this where I die
okay so don't touch the thing and oh my
god oh my god oh my god
this way
yes I'm on that I get him did I get him
I got him okay been a while since I
played this level what happened I killed
it I broke everything all right let's do
this how do i how do I go oh I'm going
let's see okay turn left and then go
very care don't hit that no okay all
right walk into that there we go
doubt me you're a jewel asons let's go
all right huh this way
leaning
Oh
oh my god super big God my face you know
not about those it's about oh my god
I'm gonna sword thank you I'm dead one
more go one bar I can do this
thank you my adoring fan thank you Holly
yeah I guess
where are you back there okay take this
nice and easy now
very slow deliberate movements yeah
when I don't take this completely
ridiculously it actually works out quite
well there we go
yeah go this way come on come on I can
jump I can jump did someone say I could
jump
all right hey who's that you know
whoa hey hey hey hold on there for a
second
oh no there
okay oh good oh those aren't enemies
oh-oh that's hard
really oh wait no wait you're over there
oh whoops
hey was I looking there the whole time
okay good okay oh man I was amazing
I was absolutely incredible sorry I
almost broke everything okay so that was
the Omni by virtue X yes yeah by virtue
X and that was absolutely incredible
like seriously that was one of the most
intent I've never had anything in gaming
like that before because it was
literally like I was there I mean the
oculus rift is really cool but this kind
of added just a whole new level of I
don't even know I don't even know how to
express it I was like I was walking for
the first time like a baby fawn just
like got born and those well once I got
into it and actually took it normally
like not a crazy person it kind of went
like it felt natural I mean there was
some things with like side strafing I
don't know if that worked right or if I
was doing that right but I was kind of
being able to get into it and maneuver a
bit better than I was before so that was
really really cool again the whole goal
of virtual reality in the Omni with the
rift and then the stem technology as
well if they get you into more natural
experience yeah more intuitive they can
feel and that's what will create a
better virtual reality yeah yeah
definitely and that was something beyond
everything I've ever seen I mean I've
seen like the progression through
arcades you know you got the gloves on
you're punching and I've had the 3d
thing but with the oculus rift combined
with this is just like completely
different is the first time that's
actually going to be able to
yeah taking up a huge room and costing
ridiculous amounts of money finally were
able to give you consumer ready version
of virtual reality yeah yeah and that's
solar cool I highly recommend if you
ever get a chance to try this out or
when it comes out it might just be worth
it because this was the most fun I had I
can't I can't even begin to understand
how a horror game would feel playing
this because I played a horror game with
the oculus rift and I was totally scared
out of my mind if I was actually on this
I would try to run away like I'm able to
run yeah I know
and that'd be like totally differently
would totally change up how immersive
games like horror games and stuff are
done so yeah I mean thanks so much for
try thanks or something but yeah thank
you
and there's been um knee vibart whips
another really cool thing that I got to
try while I was at PAX were these motion
trackers called The Sixth Sense and they
had this playable demo that I couldn't
resist trying out take a look it's not
oh yeah who can buy them Oh caress the
ball and this is my favorite ball reach
behind you behind there right no one
behind me one hand just one one MLA just
give it a big toss like a real toss not
a KB toss a real big dog oh sorry about
the throw you know give me the
ball come here God dang it you're trying
to Palm it sorry about rubbing your leg
there you were all friends here
alright star god you get back here you
little a hole draw got it yeah all right
huh okay so and then get that look you
would I throw it into another dimension
okay it's gone it's it disappearing
okay I see a butterfly Can I grab it
I'm coming for you butterfly I'm coming
for you I'm gonna get ya I'm wait
where'd you go
what's good ah just our reach Oh God
humma oh yeah got it oh yeah all right
you just ditch em there's one huh yeah I
were to go way to go way to go there is
no more gotcha
come on come here I'm gonna get off you
stupid do I look chases like oh oh
come here you bastard where'd you go aah
oh no something's happened to my elbow
that's okay get it gonna remember
whoever I got yeah yeah yeah okay grab
it and what beat the crap out of this
butterfly to yak okay hi fancy grabbing
room
oh whoops I think I killed him I think
he's dead that is a dead butterfly
okay all right moving on oh oh ah oh oh
oh so I'm gonna lean around the corner
whoo-hoo Dodger you can totally imagine
if I was hiding in a horror again
doesn't like running away from a monster
arm and take some shots now you son of a
gun I'm gonna slap the crap out of you
when I get over there
no okay I'm done all right I'm going out
let's get you out of here
all right well you know I am hi welcome
back
oh I'm in the real world again imagine
combine these two yeah that was so cool
that was like the coolest thing I'm
sweating again and I was just sitting
down
boxing at school yeah but anyway yeah
this has been Oh the sixth sense let's
see the sixth sense true motion dev kit
that's Rises our five point tracking
system coming up with Kickstarter next
one yeah I mean that was actually really
in touch I mean the oculus rift is
something amazing but to actually be
able to have my hands down in there was
this on the cool I mean at first it
looked like I was fumbling but that's
just like anything takes a learning
curve and after a while is finally able
to get it and actually move around and
get a sense of like I was in there and
the weirdest thing was when the octaves
rift came off it was very jarring to be
suddenly back here and realized that
there's a ton of people behind me
watching what I'm doing but that was
still really really cool I mean thank
you so much for letting me try by
fantastic yeah thanks again everybody
he'll see you in the next video bye bye
what's that outro that I do I always
forget what I do